AND SHE'S ENJOYING IT TOO.
LOOK AT THAT.
LOOK ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THAT
PHONE.
JOIN US RIGHT NOW, NANCY PELOSI,
SENATOR TOM COTTON.
WELCOME, TONIGHT AT 9:00, THE
HOUSE IS GOING TO VOTE ON
SOMETHING ON THE BIPARTISAN
BILL, WE THINK.
EVEN THOUGH SOME OF OUR REPORTS
SAY THEY WON'T, ON A BIPARTISAN
BILL.
DO YOU THINK IT WILL HAPPEN?
>> I DON'T KNOW, BRIAN.
I CAN CONFIRM THAT I WAS NOT ON
THE OTHER SIDE OF THAT PHONE
CALL WITH NANCY PELOSI LAST
NIGHT.
I THINK THE HOUSE IS GOING TO
HAVE TO VOTE SO LATE BECAUSE
NANCY PELOSI AND HER RADICAL
DEMOCRATIC LEFT ARE OUT LOOKING
FOR THE TREE AROUND THE CAPITOL
ON WHICH ALL OF THIS FREE MONEY
GROWS, BRIAN.
JOE MANCHIN PUT IT WELL TODAY.
THEY WANT TO TRANSFORM THIS
COUNTRY WITH A SOCIALIST AGENDA.
BETWEEN THE $2 TRILLION BILL
THEY PASSED IN MARCH, THE $1
TRILLION INFRASTRUCTURE BILL
THEY WANT NOW.
AND EVEN IF YOU GO WITH JOE'S
$1.5 TRILLION WELFARE BILL, IT
WOULD BE $4.5 TRILLION IN
SPENDING, BRIAN.
THAT'S TAXES ON EVERY FAMILY IN
AMERICA.
IT'S SPENDING FOR ILLEGAL ALIENS
AND DEADBEATS THAT WON'T LOOK
FOR WORK, MUCH LESS WORK.
DEMOCRATS ARE REALIZING HOW
UNPOPULAR THE AGENDA IS.
THAT'S WHY NANCY PELOSI IS
CORRALLING THOSE VOTES.
>> BRIAN: I RISK CONFUSING
PEOPLE.
TWO SEPARATE BILLS.
SO-CALLED MODERATES TO SAY I
WANT THE BILL IN THE SENATE TO
PASS.
YOU DIDN'T VOTE FOR IT.
OTHERS DID.
THE MODERATES SAID NANCY PELOSI,
DO IT BY THE 27th OF SEPTEMBER.
WELL, IT'S SEPTEMBER 30, AND
THEY'RE GOING TO VOTE TODAY.
IF THEY DON'T VOTE FOR IT,
KIRSTEN SINEMA AND OTHER
MODERATES SAY THEY'RE OUT WHEN
IT COMES TO THE 3.5 OR ANY OTHER
COMPROMISE.
IF THEY DON'T HAVE THE VOTE
TONIGHT, EVEN IF IT FAILS, THE
MODERATES BALLING, IF THEY DO
HAVE THE VOTE, THE LIBERALS
DON'T VOTE FOR IT.
NANCY GETS A FAIL, JOE BIDEN
GETS A LOSS TEMPORARILY.
ARE THEY WILLING TO RISK THAT?
>> YOU LAID IT OUT WELL.
I WOULD SAY THEY'RE IN DISARRAY.
BUT I DON'T WANT TO APPLY THEY
WERE IN ARRAY.
THIS GANG RIGHT NOW COULDN'T
ORGANIZE A ONE-CAR FUNERAL.
THE ONE THING THEY CAN AGREE ON
IS THEY WANT TO TAKE MORE OF
YOUR MONEY AND GIVE IT AWAY FOR
YOUR PRIORITIES LIKE WELFARE FOR
ILLEGALS.  .
SO, YOU SHOULD NEVER COUNT THE
DEMOCRATS OUT.
NO MATTER HOW BAD IT LOOKS FOR
THEM WHILE THEY'RE MAKING THE
SAUSAGE.
IN THE END, WHAT THEY CARE ABOUT
IS TAKING YOUR MONEY AND GETTING
MANIER POWER.
>> BRIAN: -- AND GETTING MORE
POWER.
>> BRIAN: YOU DO BELIEVE
SOMETHING IS GOING TO COME OUT
OF THIS.
DID IT SHOCK YOU IN AUGUST THAT
JOE MANCHIN PUT A PEN TO PAPER
AND CHUCK SCHUMER AND SAY I'M
NOT GOING TO GO ALONG WITH 3.5,
I'LL GO ALONG WITH 1.5.
I WON'T SIGN OFF ON ANYTHING
UNTIL OCTOBER 1.
EVERY TIME THEY TALKED ABOUT THE
3.5, THEY KNEW EXACTLY WHAT HE
WANTED.
CHUCK SCHUMER WOULDN'T TALK
ABOUT.
BRING ME BEHIND THE SCENE THERE
IS TO THE CLOAKROOM.
WHAT'S HAPPENING?
>> FIRST OFF, BRIAN, I'VE NEVER
SEEN SUCH A DOCUMENT IN MY
ENTIRE POLITICAL LIFE, NOT AS
LONG AS CHUCK SCHUMER'S OR JOE
MANCHINS'S, BUT WHEN WE HAVE OUR
DIFFERENCES, WE TALKED THEM OUT,
WE DON'T SIGN CONTRACTS WITH
EACH OTHER. BUT SECOND, I THINK
CHUCK SCHUMER HAS SOME
EXPLAINING TO DO WITH HIS FELLOW
DEMOCRATS.
YOU POINTED OUT.
JOE MANCHIN HAS BEEN UP FRONT
WITH HIM IN THE BEGINNING.
NOW I STRONGLY DISAGREE WITH
WHAT SENATOR MANCHIN PO PROPOSED
IN THAT MEMO.
CHUCK SCHUMER KNEW ABOUT IT FOR
A COUPLE OF MONTHS.
HE'S LEANING ON THE FAR LEFT OF
HIS CAUCUS TO BELIEVE THEY'RE
GOING TO GO FOR BROKE IN THE
$3.5 TRILLION BILL.
I'M WONDERING IF CHUCK SCHUMER
IS HEARING SOME FOOTSTEPS FROM
AOC IN THE NEW YORK PRIMARY NEXT
YEAR.
>> BRIAN: REALLY QUICK, 168 OF
THE 2,000 PAGE BILL, WE'RE
LOOKING FOR FINES $70,000 TO DLB
700,000.
THAT WILL DESTROY SO MANY SMALL
BUSINESSES.
THE IRS GOES ON STEROIDS.
YOU THINK THEY'RE GOING AFTER
AMAZON, YOU'RE DREAMING?
THEY'RE GOING AFTER SMALL
BUSINESS.
FINAL THOUGHT?
>> YEAH, ALL OF THE EFFORTS FOR
BUREAUCRACY, WHETHER IT'S THE
CODED POLICE FORCE OR GIVING IRS
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO
COME AFTER SMALL BUSINESSES TO
PUT MORE POWER IN THE HANDS OF